- [Host] Let's talk about football.
- [Co-Host] Blue, 42.
This football, right?
- [Host] No, today, we're
talking about this football.
- [Co-Host] Soccer?
- [Host] No, it's football.
You have the players, the
managers, and the tea.
- [Co-Host] The tea?
- [Host] Mr. Parish, please explain.
- Welcome to you all, to
Nottingham Forest F.C.,
and have a great time while you're here.
And don't forget, if you can,
try a cup of my Tom's Tea.
(laughs) The best.
- [Host] Nottingham Forest is one
of the oldest football clubs in the world.
They had a great run about 40 years ago,
winning two European cups
and loads of other stuff.
- No, I'm very proud of this team.
Happy days.
- [Host] But whilst those days are gone,
there's still one world-class
tradition that remains.
- Well, my name is Tom Parish.
I'm almost 89 now, not
long before the 90th.
I'm a tea boy, and I love it.
People will say, "A tea boy?"
I said, "Yeah, I worked
my way up." (chuckles)
- [Host] Here in Britain,
it was a common occurrence
for football clubs to have
a tea lady or a tea boy.
Sadly, these traditions
are on the decline.
But, what does a tea boy do?
- Oh, crikey, what does the tea boy do?
He makes tea, of course.
- [Host] So Tom isn't handing
out tea at the sideline.
He has his own kitchen next
to the teams' dressing rooms.
- Let me show you around.
- [Host] His job is to
make classic cups of tea
for managers, players,
directors, photographers.
- That was one of our photographers.
Yes, he's a good lad.
- [Host] The list goes on.
So Tom, what are your
top tips for making tea?
- You get the best tea,
and that is Yorkshire Tea.
Boiling water over the tea bag.
Get it to the sides of the cup
and squeeze it as much as you can
to get the juice out of the tea bag.
Put your milk in.
That should be, I hope, a good cup of tea.
(cheering)
- It's not just a football match.
It's something that you look forward to,
and it's there every week.
That's what keeps you going.
And, I love it, love it.
As long as I can walk, and
that the club will have me,
I'll be here making a cup of tea.